so you might have heard about this
pharma company that raised the price of
its drug by more than 5,000% the
reaction particularly when you read the
papers today has been quite critical of
this move so why well you know we needed
to turn a profit on the drug that's
Martin shkreli the CEO of Turing
pharmaceuticals he bought an old drug
called daraprim which treats
life-threatening diseases in HIV
patients an overnight raised the price
from thirteen fifty cents a pill to
seven hundred and fifty dollars that
caused outrage Hillary Clinton tweeted
about price gouging biotech stops
dropped into a bear market and even
Pharma the industry's lobby group in
Washington distanced itself from Turing
but raising prices is actually pretty
common in the industry tick marks
januvia millions of Americans used to
treat diabetes when Mark started selling
the pill in 2006 costs about one hundred
and forty six dollars a month by 2011 it
was 213 dollars a month now 30 days
worth of januvia costs 331 dollars more
than twice what it did when Merck
brought it to market adjusted for
inflation were still seeing big price
increases Novartis is cancer drug
Gleevec more than tripled in price from
2001 when it cost thirty two thousand
dollars to one hundred and eighteen
thousand dollars a year today and Pfizer
raised prices on 133 of its drugs in the
last year so why did drug prices keep
going up for one drug makers say ORD is
risky and expensive the industry says it
spent more than fifty billion dollars on
rd just last year and most drugs failed
somewhere between the test tube and the
many clinical trials the FDA requires
before medicines okayed for sale to the
public for the drugs that do get
approved on average they have about 12
years of dominance before cheap generics
come on the market and create
competition since the US doesn't
regulate drug prices pharmaceutical
companies try to make as much profit as
they can before those generics come to
market in fact Pfizer made about a
billion dollars more over the last two
years just because of price increases on
their drugs in the case of Turing
pharmaceuticals CEO Martin shkreli
responded to angry calls by promising to
lower the price of daraprim without
saying by how much
tering is an extreme example but the
reality is drug companies have been
doing it for years and aren't likely to
change